also ich bin so aufgeregt ist nicht mehr
drüber und halbe leben ich hab halbe
leben ich hab drei herzlich willkommen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren zu
einer weiteren wunderschönen ausgabe
unseres morde vereinten adeligen in
deutschland war sind zwei stören da sind
zwei leute drauf cars crafter und er ist
immer komm schnell drauf geht doch ich
glaube ich glaube ich konnte doch nicht
kommen ich sehe die du siehst wie wo ich
sie auch wo bist du kommen hat meinen
koordinaten und so gut ist wie die
laubhaufen mich zu ich hab ich hab' ich
komme ich komm ich komponiert ich
komponiere größter spannend für mich
geht das geld aus sie mich kennst du
mich ich bin hinten dran
frage ich bin im wasser gesprungen ich
bin wasser gesprungen war darauf bin ich
auch soll ich sonst eine runde laufen so
eine runde laufen oder wie einfach
einfach einfacher ich bin schon direkt
hin dran
ich bin direkt hin dran ich wurde heftig
weggeboxt doch gerade dort warte warte
warte ich bin am morgen dran
ich bin am morgen dran so kassner game
passt caracas charakter ich bin ein
kleid com ag im kommentar zum morgen
erinnern ich bin einkaufskraft da dran
ich bin da krasse kraft oder also ich
bin so aufgeregt ist es nicht mehr
normal lastzug us-kräfte das zeigen
jetzt gehen wartet rwe schließt mit
bogenschießen den bogen zu werden schon
halb aufgebraucht alter ich wurde
anderes zu wem ich weiß es nicht aber
ich bin ich muss sich konzentrieren okay
ganz ruhig ganz ruhig ganz ruhig die
gamescom morgens kommt ja ja ich komme
ich komm ich kommt dass christa karas
crafter cars crafter einmal getroffen
zweimal caspar walter ich bin so
aufgeregt ist nicht mehr drüber ich hab
halbe leben ich habe halbe leben ich
habe drei oder im herzen zweieinhalb
herzen ein herz
du kannst
kom kom kom kom kom kom kom kom kommt
castro zumindestens oft [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
nein nein nein
doch ich bin voll aufgeregt ich bin voll
gestillt keine ahnung was wir noch
machen sollen
ich schaue auf die zwei spiele am
horizont wo es noch bei twitter an
alvaro teilnehmer puls ist nicht mehr
normal ist dass als und dann dann hat so
gut angefangen dann hat so gut
angefangen ja mit cast crafter und sonst
was
dann war das problem dass wir uns nicht
irgendwie konzentriert und gemeinsam
hagen auch noch nach der letzten folge
mir gesagt du hast du dich einloggen und
dann ja was ich aus glock heavy rain war
gar nicht beieinander jahr so gut 30 wer
kein pferd also kein ding und seht ja
auch nicht von uns eine offene server
sein wenn wir aufnehmen und so jung
jetzt haben die einfach mal meine
schärfe drei dir schwer meine komplette
rüstung werden das gewinnen glaube ich
oder dort ist doch noch stark drei
bogenschießen ja ich hab sogar auf den
geschossen
diddy diddy müssten eigentlich relativ
viel weiter und morgenarbeit ich warte
ja auch ein gamer ich habe auch keine
gamer tastatur da so wo ich dann
irgendwie super springen kann oder keine
dieses pv habe ich auch nur auf 44 habe
ich auch gar nichts weiß ich war die die
bahn die waren halt jetzt beide und ich
hatte angst davor ganz gut und ging 2
kommt so einfach nicht an
das ist es dass das war nicht drin und
was ich weiß jetzt ich hab den op apfel
am anfang gegessen aber zu früh glaube
ich und das war auch irgendwie ich
glaube das war auch ich hab ich habe
gesagt gib mir die mal den op ab
vielleicht nicht so gut im pvp bin mir
die ganzen die ganzen folgen haben wir
daraufhin gearbeitet wie verrückt und
sehe ich wie die daneben war irgendwie
ihr dass ich sie unsere ganze einem side
assist systems server es ist als kind
bekommen und hätte jetzt gibt zwei
methoden auf dem boden
ich bin mit einer kiste die am alle
unsere das sind das sind ja zwei mit
ihnen hat wie viel haben die ihr zweck
rotzig glaubens bei 7 kills oder sowas
ja gut
was soll das ich gehe da man vom server
ich bleibe da auf ewig darauf die den
ganzen den ganzen bildschirm verfügt du
erstmal eine letzte worte ja also was
ich natürlich hoffe ist dass ihr
trotzdem in unserer kombination sparrate
wir haben viel mühe gegeben hier vor
allem kommentar technisch unterhaltung
unterhalte risch nicht dass wir ihnen
die sagen ja wir sind 15 war wir waren
auch in ja wir waren viele munter und
das ist klar aber nicht dass wir gesagt
dann okay wir wurden einfach hier
straight durch die wand deswegen bin ich
ja mal anhören gegangen kinos auch dann
immer so ein bisschen so auf den
kommentaren geachtet dass wir nicht
beide in minen sind und so was alles
unterstellt darauf geachtet
aber ich muss auch sagen von den
zuschauern kam auch eine super kritik
also super
nicht kritik positive kritik zur presse
die fanden das gut
ich wollte einen film machen indem brühl
studio aber das regt mich das regt mich
echt auf weil ich muss jetzt erst mal so
nebenbei die karten auf den tisch legen
dass ich während war auch bewusst zu
viel pvp gespielt habt ihr noch nie und
ich dachte dass ich eigentlich zumindest
in der börse wurden anständig was reißen
kann
aber irgendwie jetzt die beiden dann
darauf den tisch sein das ist das ist
scheiße gelaufen da hätten wir taktisch
irgendwie sie war einfach besser
ja deswegen natürlich auch ganz klar das
müssen wir immer dazu erwähnen lasst
bitte keinen keinen hate bei mister x
oder beim castroper dar das wir haben
wir an das jahr herausgefordert werden
die letzten beiden und ich fand ehrlich
gesagt obwohl das ist jetzt zu einem
aufeinandertreffen kam ja ich fand es
ehrlich gesagt cool weil ich habe das
noch vor der aufnahme sagt dann wollen
wir jetzt eigentlich noch ein warum
machen weil es ist halt wirklich so sein
projekt wisst ihr dass das ist halt
wirklich minecraft vanilla in normalen
treffer müller hält man sich dann jetzt
halt noch ein haus gebaut und noch eine
farm und weil sich mit redstone probiert
aber das ist halt ein pvp projekt und
ihr kennt das wahrscheinlich wenn ihr
hunger games spielt und ihr habt die
besten alters und ihr denkt zu jetzt
will ich nur noch kämpfen
da will man ja dann nicht irgendwie sich
die landschaft angucken das oder will
man dann ja wirklich den konflikt suchen
und mit anderen leuten kämpfe und genau
so ist das halt hier auch das ist halt
wirklich nur risiken sondern da geht es
um sterben und töten und von daher fand
ich es eigentlich ganz gut dass jetzt in
unseren konflikt zustande kam
ich bin jetzt nicht so einer der sagt
solari häufig server oben kommt den
dollar auf dem server und tötet uns fand
ich gut fand ich habe auch einfach noch
nie so gelacht meine aufnahme glaube ich
eine minute durch gleichen
computerspielen mehr hatten alter ist
sie wirklich ist jetzt komplett
desillusioniert vom rechner ehrlich ich
mich fast so mit sich dass wir uns
einfach vorher noch vonseiten jahr so
angst es zumindest wünscht so für die
für die zuschauer die jetzt irgendwie
noch was auf uns gesetzt haben dass wir
da irgendwie ich fühle mich so endlich
fühle mich bei sowas schnell schuldig
ich hätte gern noch ein bisschen was
gerissen muss ich sagen
aber natürlich war es cool ich finde
auch cool dass das jetzt hier zu seinem
epischen ende bei uns gekommen ist und
wer hat nicht irgendwie durch durch lava
oder so einen scheiß gestorben sind ich
werde allerdings mit mit freuden die
folge von monk erst anschauen haben dass
ich zumindest einen irgendwie dass ich
zumindest einem so ein bisschen in der
aufnahme schrecken gemacht hat und
dachte ich wäre eine eine gefahr gewesen
und ist halt jetzt ist es irgendwie
irgendwas ist ja wie hoffenheim
verhärtet der spaß und das ist ja das
wichtigste sache und irgendjemand musste
musste ja noch mal ohne ohne irgend
jemand anders zu killen von dann gehen
und das war top 10 gewinnt das ding ich
hab immer immer wenn du in diese ware
konnte geschah das im jemand aufgenommen
danach kann und so hoffen wir tot und
das thema zum glück bin ich nicht und
ich weiß jetzt schon geknallt werden
oder vielleicht steht schon drin oder
sonst was ich habe geschrien hersteller
steckt hashtag die gleiche erstreckt
leute lasst auf jeden fall eine
spitzenbewertung da wir dann schauen wie
es mit also bis etwa an sich weitergeht
steht noch nicht fest vielleicht wird zu
einem jährlichen event da wird noch ein
bisschen rum diskutiert was allerdings
sicher feststeht ist dass sowohl conti
als auch ich schon neue projekte geplant
haben also neue große minecraft bilder
sind schon
geile sachen planung ein richtig geiles
1 1 was auskuriert als so ein bisschen
ein bisschen übergang mäßig bis zum
richtig bescheid wahrscheinlich passt
ich dachte du bist ein bisschen dirty
sonntag wahrscheinlich auch schon die
tage an mal gucken wenn wir daran
irgendetwas finden
das bringt jetzt auch nichts mehr ist
passiert beim nächsten mal was
vielleicht besser und ich werde weiter
versuchen an meinem pvp skills zu
arbeiten und vielleicht kriege ich daher
an weiteren projekten irgendwas gewissen
hier hat jetzt auch einfach
also ich natürlich tierisch aufregen ich
bin jetzt noch ich war alles als ich
gemerkt habe dass sie wirklich einen
kampf drin und sind wirklich am
wegrennen und sowas dass das das waren
ganz anderes gefühl und alles was ich
irgendwie in diesen pvp runden davor
also leute die meine leistung zu folgen
so wissen wir dass das ich da schon ab
und zu was reißen kann
all das was ich mir da immer dieses cool
bleiben als elementar sind solchen camp
habe ich total über bord geschmissen
erwiesen
die drittklässler der gerade eben das
ist das erste mal ein kuss macht oder so
dass die komische vielleicht ja weil sie
nicht also was sicher noch mal sagen
möchte ist dass es wirklich cool war
dass ihr uns so viele tipps abgegeben
habt sowas wie mit den büchern
verzaubern und keine ahnung was du was
geht uns da auch noch mal alles
geschrieben habe dafür möchte ich mich
auf jeden fall bedanken dass er wirklich
mit seiner leidenschaft dabei war die
wir quasi also wir haben uns daher
wirklich wir haben uns da wirklich mal
abends dann wirklich einfach
sprachnotizen geschickt was wir machen
könnten in dem projekt und so was alles
also wir haben uns da schon so ein
bisschen rein gesteigert das muss man
schon sagen weil wir wirklich danach in
diesem willen hatten das ganze zu
beginnen aber ich finde es jetzt auch
nicht schlecht dass es so geendet ist
also ich sag jetzt nicht ja voll durch
das sie uns angegriffen haben wir
wollten das ja so von daher finde ich
das eigentlich alles ganz cool aber auf
jeden fall ein großes danke an euch
wollte ich nur sagen
und sonst gar nicht mehr zu sagen außer
dass war die letzte folge waren ja bis
irgendwann
ja
mit
denn
nicht
kukksi
ja
bekannt
m